often visits this Memorial in nyange
during the 1994 genocide a Catholic
Church stood here up to 2 000 Tutsis who
had taken refuge in the church were
killed
militia from the Hutu Community tried to
set the building on fire and when that
failed they demolished it with a
bulldozer mukagachire was on her way to
the church when the attack happened her
parents and other relatives were killed
she says fulgence kaishma was a
well-known police officer in the area
I was concerned when he came to a
funeral and refused to allow us to bury
our neighbor I also had him tell Young
Who to men to prepare to kill the Tutsis
and slaughter their cattle that's why we
decided to go to the church
kaishma was arrested in South Africa
after two decades On The Run he's
accused of organizing the massacre it's
a real being here it's hard to imagine
the terror as people try to find their
way out they thought they would be safe
in church but that was not the case
had brought his five children to the
church none survived
others brought petrol to burn down the
church they brought the bulldozer he was
in charge the priest was also involved
he allowed the militia to come in he
instructed them to demolish the church
and everyone in it he is currently in
jail
back at the memorial mugakashire shows
us names of her relatives and friends
we're very happy kaishima is in police
custody he did a terrible thing I hope
he will be brought to wonder to faces he
must pay for what he did
mukagachira says she survived because
her Hutu neighbors heed her in a shallow
grave and a Pete latrine
Catherine soy Al Jazeera nyange genocide
Memorial Ronda